remember Leon Brittan as one of the most
brilliant politicians of his generation
a Rolls Royce brain you know maybe we
thought there were more of in those days
than they clap diaper Joe's we have to
put up with increasingly today I think
he could have lived a very privileged
life as a high-powered barrister making
lots of money and said of which he
worked really hard to get himself into
Parliament you know Leon would not have
said there was any prejudice as to why
he didn't get in but I would say that
there Michael critically of course half
fear and then as soon as he got in of
course he became one of the key people
in Margaret Thatcher's team because you
know she provided the rhetorical lead
but it needed really hard-working
dedicated people to carry through some
of these reforms and you know I was at
the home office of five years a lot of
them with him and I just remember it was
exhilarating to be doing
you
if this and he was an inspiring leader I
never heard him say a bad word about
anybody I never saw him do anything was
intellectually arrogant but we knew that
if you know but he would discectomies
sometimes not to our advantage but he
would do it with a kindly man you know
he wasn't a lucky politician or Minister
though he got into trouble at the Home
Office over policy matters and then got
caught in the crossfire as it's been put
in the Western efendim in the fight
between Tarzan and the slightly
overpowering Jane yeah yes he wasn't a
lucky politician actually because um it
wasn't his fault and even and Hesseltine
was very generous about him today and
said it wasn't his fault
Byron berline talking to me at the time
he was offered the european commissioner
ship saying that i think he was right
that he should take it and i said yes if
you don't think you're ever going to be
a really big have a big cabinet post
again because you're too good to waste
and he took it on and then you know he
got him most people forget we now send
third-rate people don't wait to be
commissioners people aren't even
household names in her own front rooms
but leon was a major figure and he got
involved in um trade negotiations where
you got to have a a big brain and be a
big ability to you know push boredom to
one side he did a great job there
although it wasn't what he wanted to do
but he did it because he was that kind
of guy he was of course a leading
pro-european as he proved a different
commissioner again that's a big change
with today's conservative pop yes it's
almost more interesting you know whether
people like leon who are big pro
europeans you know whether they would
still be in the european world of today
but you know the tragedy there are two
tragedies involved in this interlink one
a man like Leon Brittan who is a lovely
fellow I mean I had loved him not so
long ago lovely lovely man
delightful companion he shouldn't have
died at 75 which we now don't think of
as a great age but also he died at an
inconvenient time for his reputation
Alijah I like Simon Dan chalky and I
when Ken isn't around he prevents my LBC
show with me he's a nice chap but you
see everybody is spinning a yarn a
tissue of untruths and myths about
Geoffrey Dickens in his Richard dasya
nobody knows what was in that dossier
knowing Geoffrey as we all did there's
no reason to believe it was some
carefully thought through set of
allegations I mean no doubt Leon Brittan
would have handed that into the Home
Office to be worked upon after all if
there were criminal allegations you know
it's not for the home sake you know very
well David Miller that that at the time
leave Geoffrey Dickens to one side there
were constantly rumors and insinuations
against neil Leon Brittan in this area
yes which you know I also did not did
not believe but I think you know there
are some people to whom rumours attach
but I can tell you I've spent a lot of
time at that period with Leon you get to
know a chap very well and I tell you
what he was I think one of the finest
had the best brain of any politician I
worked with and I just don't think that
some of these sort of you know sexual
tittle-tattle that I believe to be
answered no one's ever substantiated any
of this and it's a shame he dies people
won't remember for 20 or 30 years that
he spent doing a job that paid little
and as we can see offered little by the
way of reward of public adulation he
could have lived a very privileged life
and now all he gets is you know what did
Geoffrey Dickens say to him we all know
that Geoffrey would have just put in
some stuff that he'd been given by the
tabloid press which they couldn't
publish but they eat they thought he
presented it to the home segment that
there is now stuff about that period
which is coming out which we were
unaware of at the time which is very
shocking but that's the point yeah I can
tell you as the father of two young boys
in the 80s as a home of his minister if
I'd had any idea that somebody I was
sort of in the division Lobby with was
actually some active pedophile I can
assure you I'd have dealt with it with
the same alacrity that you know one when
dealt with some other things not always
making one solves a lot of friends along
the way
I am totally and utterly certain that
Leon Brittan would never have been party
to any kind of cover-up of anything like
that the extraordinary thing and I am
astonished by it is you know the idea
Special Branch intervene to protect Saul
Smith I would they have done that but if
they did there was obviously stuff going
on that reached the levels that um that
we were at but and I think it should be
cleansed but I think Leon his reputation
should not be besmirched by something
that you know a half an hour meeting
with a headline seeking conservative
back venture David mouth thank you very
much